les inégalités n'était pas bien plus
grande il ya 300 ans qu'aujourd'hui
oui je crois qu'il faut renoncer à
s'intéresser à des statistiques
concernant le gia était qu'ils agissent
de l'histoire ou de l'époque actuelle
parce que on en a discuté tout à l'heure
il ya tout plein de raisons qui
permettent de dire que tout
toutes ces prétendus mesure des
inégalités sont absurdes
on parle de de distribution des
richesses illégal ou de redistribution
ce qui est une expression également
contestable parce que ça laisse supposer
implicitement que les richesses
appartiennent à la collectivité ou à
l'état et que et elles doivent être elle
doivent être répartis de manière
égalitaire en fonction des statistiques
que l'on que l'on fournit et bien ça me
paraît parfaitement discutable il
faudrait arrêter de parler voulait dire
que chacun créant ses propres richesses
exactement il n'y a pas à les comparer
la richesse est créée n'est pas
distribuée et donc à n'est pas un n'a
pas être redistribuées mais pourquoi
justement on fait des statistiques et
des études empiriques sur ce qu'on
appelle les inégalités parce que ça
justifie la politique économique de
redistribution
ça permet aux politiciens d'exister
on trouve toujours une majorité de gens
pour essayer de prendre deux des
ressources à d'autres et l'état par
conséquent sous prétexte de réduire les
inégalités crée des inégalités
puisqu'il le il vole davantage de
ressources à certains qu'à d'autres
[Musique]